merci beaucoup Jean-Claude maillet
d'avoir accepté notre invitation ce
matin c'est un secrétaire général de
Force Ouvrière entre 2004 et 2018 vous
êtes actuellement vice-président du
cercle de réflexion sinopia synopsia
pardon et on va évidemment parler de la
réforme des retraites avec vous on est à
la quatrième la veille de la quatrième
journée de grève on va en parler mais
cette nuit je voudrais vous faire réagir
à ça d'abord cette nuit Emmanuel Macron
qui était à Bruxelles a dit compter sur
l'esprit de responsabilité des syndicats
pour que le mouvement contre la réforme
des retraites ne bloque pas la vie du
reste du pays vous entendez ce message
il vous paraît opportun non finalement
je considère que c'est pas plus mal
quand il ne parle pas parce que c'était
tout le monde dit il s'exprime peu en ce
moment sur la question des retraites si
c'est pour appeler les syndicats à la
responsabilité enfin faut qu'ils
regardent les choses depuis le début du
mouvement ils sont plus que responsables
ils sont très responsables donc c'est
pas c'est pas faut pas les accuser à
priori de je ne sais quoi donc non ça
aurait été mieux qu'il parle d'autre
chose
il a le droit enfin vous savez quand
vous démarrez une discussion en disant
mais ça voilà ça on y touche pas ça rend
les choses compliquées
c'est la première qui se déroulera un
week-end vous attendez une forte
mobilisation la dernière vous a un petit
peu déçu non écoutez vous savez c'est ça
va ça vient ce genre de chose j'en ai
organisé avec d'autres pas mal ça
devient comprendre qu'en plus quand vous
annoncez une journée dans la semaine une
journée le week-end il y a des gens qui
disent on ira ce weekend c'est plus
simple quoi voilà donc le week-end en
général sont des des gens qui d'habitude
ne viennent pas manifester ou qui
peuvent venir en famille donc à priori
devrait y avoir beaucoup de monde demain
vous vous en avez organisé comment on
décide d'une telle stratégie est-ce que
par exemple organiser deux journées dans
la même semaine ça vous paraît opportun
oui ça peut ça peut se faire écouter on
est c'est un mouvement qui est géré par
l'ensemble des organisations syndicales
l'unité est réelle et elle perdure et ça
c'est un mouvement qui est dans la durée
et alors c'est vrai que c'est pas
toujours simple parce que il faut à la
fois une pression suffisante pour faire
reculer un gouvernement tout en gardant
le soutien de la population donc il y a
un côté fil du rasoir en permanence
c'est difficile à trouver cet équilibre
oui la question quand on a la tête d'un
syndicat de savoir où est la limite où
est le curseur bien sûr alors après
quand vous êtes responsable d'un
syndicat vous gérez pas tout je veux
dire vous n'êtes pas responsable pour
reprendre le mot de tout vous pouvez
toujours avoir un syndicat une
fédération quel que soit l'organisation
qui décide bon ben écoutez c'est pas
suffisant ben nous on décide de faire
grève ça c'est toujours possible on
n'est pas dans une entreprise avec un
PDG qui donne des ordres donc mais oui
non moi je considère que les
confédérations qui gèrent ce mouvement
le gère bien est-ce que quand on dirige
un syndicat comme vous l'avez fait
est-ce qu'on mise plutôt dans des dans
des situations comme ça sur une
mobilisation massive de la rue ou plutôt
sur des grèves suivies dans les
entreprises on démarre on démarre
souvent par des mobilisations massives
dans la rue et les plus calmes possible
et là regardez ça se passe bien en plus
globalement il y a quelques incidents
mais ça se passe ça se passe bien ça se
passe bien aussi parce qu'il y a
beaucoup de monde dans la rue c'est
beaucoup plus difficile pour certaines
intervenir et puis comme tous les
responsables syndicaux le disent les
relations avec la préfecture de police
ce sont plutôt bonnes à Paris en tous
les cas donc c'est et en fait le ça va
ailleurs que sur des mobilisations c'est
quand un moment donné si vous avez du
monde dans la rue et que le gouvernement
fasse ne bouge pas d'un iota il y a
obligatoirement des salariés des
militants vous voyez bien ça suffit pas
on fera pas bouger donc il faut qu'on
fasse autre chose donc le débat commence
à venir et il viendra c'est évident ça
veut dire qu'on va devoir arriver à des
blocages
est-ce que si vous faites des succession
de journée de mobilisation qui pour le
moment mobilisent un million de
personnes mais que vous voyez que le
gouvernement ne touche à rien ça risque
de décourager les ceux qui manifestent
et puis aussi votre base c'est toujours
possible c'est toujours possible à ce
moment-là la responsabilité je la
retourne si vous voulez quand en face
vous avez un gouvernement qui est ferme
sur ces positions qui ne bouge pas à un
moment donné la responsabilité elle est
aussi de son côté elle est partagée la
responsabilité
Emmanuel Macron cette nuit s'il y a un
blocage du pays ça sera pas la faute des
syndicats ça sera la faute du
gouvernement qui ne l'entend pas moi je
n'ai d'après ce que je comprends je suis
dans le cou aujourd'hui sur ces
questions-là mais d'après ce que je
comprends les ponts sont coupés par
exemple il y a plus de contact entre les
confédérations et le gouvernement c'est
pas normal j'ai jamais connu ça
vous vous étiez à la tête de Force
Ouvrière lors de la dernière grande
réforme en 2010 pour vous même pendant
la mobilisation parce qu'il y en a eu
vous continuez à discuter bien sûr il y
avait toujours des contacts il y avait
des contacts réguliers y compris quand
il y avait des manifestations un seul
passant de couper les contacts parce que
quel quoi qu'il arrive sur le dossier
retraite après les retraites il y aura
d'autres dossiers si ça se passe mal sur
les retraites ça augure de jours
difficile ensuite y compris après ce
dossier là donc c'est pas très malin
pardonnez-moi de couper les ponts on
peut pas c'est pas c'est un peu une
vision technocratique des choses bon
voilà il y a une séquence où on discute
avec les syndicats après on arrête et on
passe dans une séquence politique au
Parlement non les deux doivent être
doivent continuer en même temps comme ça
a été le cas ça a été le cas souvent en
2010 parce qu'on a aussi un peu envie de
savoir ce matin comment ça se passe
comment ça se passe quand on est dans la
contestation que le texte est au
Parlement comment ça se passe entre les
syndicats et le gouvernement c'est des
contacts en général qui sont pas des
grandes réunions etc c'est des contacts
des fils bilatéraux qui sont maintenus
vous avez des coups de fil vous pouvez
voir discrètement quelqu'un etc avec et
chaque organisation est concernée mais
ça permet des deux côtés d'appréhender
d'appréhender les choses parce que là
c'est rupture c'est jamais bon d'avoir
une rupture dans les discussions jamais
et en fait en 2010 c'est vrai qu'il y a
une série importante de manifestations
le contexte était différent on sortait
d'une crise financière à l'époque
c'était c'est donc on était pas une
pandémie etc c'était complètement
différent et puis à l'époque le
gouvernement en avait affiché que qu'un
seul objectif c'est il faut rétablir les
comptes on nous a pas parlé de justice
on nous a pas parlé de votre etc voilà
pour vous deux ce gouvernement de parler
de réforme juste en la présentant
surtout quand elle est injuste c'est
voilà c'est surtout ça si elle était si
c'était une réforme juste s'il pouvait
très bien se baser dessus mais c'est une
réforme qui a pas mal de caractères
d'injustice donc dire qu'elle est juste
alors qu'elle est les gens la ressentent
comme injuste ça ne passe pas ça serait
mieux passé s'ils avaient dit clairement
comme ça a été le cas lors de fois
précédente on a besoin de rétablir les
comptes il faut augmenter l'âge vous
pensez que ça c'est pas sûr non pour
cette fois je ne suis pas sûr parce que
le contexte est vraiment vraiment très
différent beaucoup de gens considèrent
attendez bon ok il va y avoir un déficit
de 12 13 milliards à terme mais on a
dépensé combien pendant la crise
sanitaire on dépense encore combien
aujourd'hui et on veut tout mettre le
pays en feu et à sang pour 12 milliards
sur les retraites alors il y a beaucoup
de gens ne comprennent pas à changer
de le regard des gens pour moi qu'il en
coûte et la pandémie le rapport au
travail se modifie tout ça n'est pas
pris en considération on a le sentiment
que présente la République qui c'est lui
qui a annoncé cette réforme au départ
j'ai compris pendant la campagne et on a
l'impression qu'il veut se faire ça pour
montrer qu'il est courageux qu'il sait
affronté une réforme difficile alors à
la fois vis-à-vis des marchés financiers
vis-à-vis de certains partenaires
européens comme l'Allemagne je pense que
c'est ça le fond le fond du dossier je
dis pas qu'il y a pas de problème de
financement mais on pourrait au moins il
pourrait au moins discuter des modalités
pour faire face à ces problèmes et puis
elle est pas urgent ça a 6 mois près
quand en 2010 quand vous étiez à la tête
de Force Ouvrière alors il y a eu des
mobilisations d'ampleur il y en a eu
plusieurs il y a eu moins de grève ou en
tout cas ça a moins pris est-ce que avec
le recul vous dites que c'était une
erreur et peut-être que les grèves ça
fait plus avancer que les mobilisations
dans la rue oui mais l'objet des
syndicats n'est pas obligatoirement de
dire bon allez on va bloquer le pays bon
une formule de ça peut arriver d'une
manière ou d'une autre
l'objet au départ c'est avoir le plus
grand soutien de la population donc de
pas les de pas ennuyer la population
c'est évident mais là aussi les
contextes à changer vous avez le
télétravail aujourd'hui par exemple bon
s'il y a les gens peuvent pas se
déplacer ce jour-là et qui doivent aller
travailler bah ils sont pour beaucoup
partis entre pas tout le monde sans la
mobilisation syndicale le télétravail
pour vous
de choses dans l'organisation de la
société c'est évident il faut tenir
compte de tout ça il aurait fallu avant
de traiter du dossier retraite discuter
sérieusement de l'emploi des seniors
discuter de du sens du travail de la
nouvelle relation au travail de
nouvelles inégalités qui apparaissent
entre ceux qui peuvent télétravailler
ceux qui ne le peuvent pas voilà il faut
il faut mieux régler les problèmes en
amont plutôt que de prendre une position
abrupte comme c'est le cas sur les
retraites que si jamais le gouvernement
continue à ne pas bouger sachant que là
le temps est compté puisque l'examen au
Parlement va très vite qu'il faut aller
vers un durcissement du mouvement vers
des grèves des grèves
là-dessus si il appartiendra aux
confédérations syndicales qui gère
ensemble le mouvement de prendre leur
responsabilité à un moment donné mais il
y a une chose dont par expérience je
suis sûr c'est que si ça peut arriver
s'il peut pas d'une manière ou avec en
force ou avec un le sentiment qu'il est
passé en force il y aura un effet
boomerang
ça en général quand vous regardez
l'histoire après 95 le mouvement de 95
il y a eu 97 changement de majorité j'ai
pas que c'est le seul élément mais ça
jouait vous regardez après 2010 le
mouvement de 2010 il y a eu 2012 Nicolas
Sarkozy a pas gagné vous regardez
c'était pas les retraites sur la loi
travail regardez ce qui est arrivé à
François Hollande bon donc il y aura un
effet boom le problème aujourd'hui c'est
que c'était faux mouvement que si la
lieu politiquement ça veut dire que
c'est celle qui peut en tirer les
marrons c'est Marine Le Pen c'est le
rassemblement national donc ça veut dire
que si c'est le cas pour un président
qui veut marquer ce sera raté ça veut
dire que ce qui est en train de se
passer là pour vous fait le jeu de
l'extrême droite
bien sûr la fois compte tenu du paysage
syndical dans les ce qu'on appelait
avant les grands partis démocratiques
que ce soit le parti socialiste ou les
républicains qui les deux on voit bien
ont des difficultés ben oui ça ferait ça
fait le jeu comportement de les filles
ou si tu pousses à la roue etc ça fait
le jeu du rassemblement national donc
cette position conduit à ça d'une
manière ou d'une autre donc on joue pas
avec la démocratie
les mobilisations se passent bien est-ce
que là aussi je fais appel à votre
expérience de leaders syndical est-ce
qu'à un moment il y a la crainte que ça
déborde et que la base vous échappe ou
est-ce que vous pensez que les syndicats
continueront à maîtriser ce qui se passe
je pense que les syndicats en tout cas
vont tout faire pour d'une manière d'une
manière ou d'une autre alors il y a
toujours eu vous savez dans l'histoire
des collectifs des coordinations un
moment donné bon mais quand les
syndicats tiennent bon c'est pas
nécessaire d'avoir ce type de mouvement
par contre suppression de la base qui se
dit mais ça peut arriver
ça toujours résister vous avez des
secteurs ou ou des entreprises parfois
quel que soit les secteurs publics ou
privés où les gens veulent en découdre
pas au début obligatoirement mais au
bout d'un moment ils ont le sentiment
qu'on les méprise ça m'est jamais bon
d'avoir le sentiment d'être méprisé
parce que vous voulez réagir donc ça a
toujours existé maintenant ça se fait
pas forcément il y a une unité syndicale
vous le dites qui pour le moment tient
vous pensez qu'elle va encore tenir vous
pensez qu'il va y avoir des stratégies
qui vont commencer très diverger entre
ceux les syndicats réformistes qui
veulent continuer un mouvement plus soft
et ceux qui veulent un peu le durer dans
tous les cas tout est fait je pense que
tout est fait pour que cette unité
perdure a pris ils ont les discussions
il y a une négo dans la négo quoi si
vous voulez donc ils discute en entre
elles elles se mettent d'accord voilà
bon non je pense que ça va durer après
il y a des nuances qui peuvent exister
si y compris sur les modalités d'action
entre les uns les autres mais quand on
veut préserver l'unité tout le monde
fait un effort vous pensez que l'unité
va durer est-ce que pour le moment c'est
pas un peu la CFDT qui est leader sur la
sur la stratégie à suivre plus que les
syndicats un peu plus durs voilà cet été
joue un rôle important y compris parce
que
plus les gens sont plus habitués y
compris le gouvernement il a dû croire à
un moment donné il s'est planté ici il a
cru ça mais que on va arriver à discuter
avec l'un ou l'autre bon le fait que la
CVT soit dans le mouvement comme les
autres aujourd'hui oui donc ça lui donne
un rôle plus important parce que c'est
plus
c'est pas régulier si vous voulez donc
ça lui donne un rôle important et son
leader s'exprime bien et pour vous c'est
la bonne stratégie oui moi je pense que
pour le moment de vu de ma fenêtre ils
suivent la bonne stratégie oui il y a
une phase de concertation parce que là
vous nous avez raconté comment ça se
passe pendant le mouvement mais en amont
avant la présentation de ce texte il y a
eu une phase de concertation est-ce que
de ce que vous en savez la méthode a été
similaire à celle que vous avez connue
vous par le passé est-ce que là le
gouvernement était à l'écoute non elle
parce qu'il y a aussi
il y a comme je sais il y a eu deux
choses la concertation il y a deux
manières de la faire en négocie pas avec
un gouvernement il y a pas de signature
à la fin la concertation où vous mais
c'est une négociation sans signature
pour me faire comprendre nous vous mais
vous tenez compte de ce que vous disent
autant interlocuteur vous bougez vous
mettez pas de vous dites pas ça on y
touchera pas voilà donc et vous mettez
tout sur la table ou alors vous
consultez voilà vous écoutez mais vous
faites ce que vous voulez ça plus
c'était ça hein la formule en fait la
négociation elle a lieu avec les
républicains la concertation avec les
syndicats voilà et la négociation avec
les républicains donc c'était on n'était
pas du tout dans ce cadre là en 2010 le
contexte était différent mais je pense
que c'est une erreur il y a une erreur
de méthode y compris sur ce de fond je
dis tout à l'heure c'est anormal qui est
pas qui est plus de discussion quoi
c'est anormal est-ce que c'est pas aussi
révélateur de la place du syndicalisme
aujourd'hui dans notre société non non
je ne pense pas mais vous voyez pas que
j'ai une chose qui m'apparaîtrait moins
importante c'est que on réforme une loi
qu'on appelle la loi l'archet qui a été
parce que à l'époque Monsieur l'archet
était ministre du Travail qui oblige un
gouvernement à consulter les
interlocuteurs sociaux quand ils
touchent un élément important du travail
et leur proposer de négocier s'il le
souhaite etc ça a été progressivement
détourné on l'a vu sur l'assurance
chômage dès 2018 l'objet de cette loi
c'était pas de dire bah voilà vous allez
discuter vous avez tant de temps et puis
voilà où vous devez arriver bah ça pue
c'est plus de négociation donc il
faudrait modifier cette loi j'invite les
sénateurs à travailler là-dessus à la
fois en mettant plus de contraintes on
peut mettre une lettre d'orientation on
peut pas mettre une lettre de cadrage
par exemple voilà faut retravailler sur
ces questions là l'étendre à la
protection sociale ce sera un beau
travail ça ce serait positif ouais mais
est-ce que du coup le fait que
effectivement le gouvernement
court-circuite un peu les syndicats même
si il dit que il y a eu négociation ça
veut pas dire qu'aujourd'hui les
syndicats ils n'ont plus le point qu'ils
avaient avant qu'ils n'ont plus le poids
qu'ils avaient quand vous vous étiez à
la tête c'est passé aussi j'étais à la
tête de fou à l'époque non non moi je
alors qu'il y ait la France a plus
souvent plus historiquement c'est du au
poids du PC de la CGT historiquement
c'est moi vrai aujourd'hui plus jouer le
conflit que la négociation ça c'est un
élément c'est vrai ça les choses sont en
train sont en train d'évoluer également
en la matière non je pense que vous
savez les États ont perdu du pouvoir au
fil du temps les gouvernements aussi à
la fois parce qu'on a pris des
engagements c'est pas l'Europe en tant
que tel mais on a pris des engagements
au niveau mon père on a pu de pouvoir
monétaire on a plus de pouvoir ou moins
de pouvoir budgétaire résultat des
courses mais il se replient sur toute la
sphère sociale d'une certaine manière on
veut contrôler complètement l'assurance
chômage alors que c'était paritaire
avant sur les retraites c'est nous qui
décidons un circuler a rien à voir voilà
et ça ce n'est pas bon y compris en
terme de démocratie sur le sur le fait
que le gouvernement était inflexible sur
les 64 ans les syndicats aussi le son en
disant pour nous c'est la borne c'est la
ligne rouge c'est est-ce que peut eux
aussi ils ont fait une erreur est-ce
qu'ils n'auraient pas dû être moins
inflexible sur cette borne et obtenir
plus de choses en échange sur la
pénibilité sur les carrières longues non
tout simplement parce que je sais pas
quand vous êtes au pouvoir que vous
savez parce que c'est pas nouveau toutes
les anciennes compris la CFDT était
contre l'histoire de l'âge donc quand
vous êtes au pouvoir que vous savez que
vous avez tous les tous ceux qui sont en
face de vous en théoriquement pour
discuter sont opposés vous regardez les
choses différemment vous disiez pas je
vais passer en force pour montrer que je
suis courageux voilà donc c'est ça vous
savez il y a plein d'inégalités
nouvelles y compris dans cette loi je
vais prendre un seul exemple vous savez
que bon les femmes quand elles ont des
enfants ont des trimestres majorations
pour trimestres etc vous prenez le cas
alors ça vous permet pas de partir avant
mais ça rentre dans le cadre de votre de
votre carrière vous prenez
une femme qui a 24 qui démarre à cotisé
à 24 trois enfants qu'est-ce qui se
passe théoriquement 24 ans plus 43 ans
elle doit aller jusqu'à 67 ans le fait
qu'elle ait eu trois enfants peut partir
à 64 une femme qui commence à 21 ans
elle va faire 21 + 43 64 donc les
trimestres pour enfants ça rendent pas
en ligne de compte voilà plus vous
reportez l'âge plus vous que générer de
nouvelles inégalités voilà c'est ça
c'est des choses qu'on devrait régler
auparavant en de il y a différentes
manières de régler un problème financier
sur les retraites or il y a des tabous
faut pas toucher au quotidien non on
touche pas au cotisations de cet exemple
sur la démographie il y a des
contestations etc donc c'est ça une
vraie concertation c'est que on dit une
position et puis après on essaie de
trouver le compromis ce qui n'est pas le
cas mais est-ce que le compromis est-ce
que le compromis ça aurait pas été par
exemple certains peuvent travailler
jusqu'à son 64 ans parce qu'ils n'ont
pas des métiers pénibles parce qu'ils
ont des métiers mais en revanche on veut
être un flexible sur certains points
est-ce que là aussi il y a pas eu un peu
de camp arc-bouter chacun sur leur
position ah bah oui mais enfin le la
position des syndicats les connaît
depuis longtemps sur l'âge ça fait des
années et des années des années depuis
la campagne présidentielle d'une
certaine manière et je pense que 65 ans
quand il a annoncé 65 ans c'était plus
pour des raisons politiques que des
raisons liées au traite donc non moi je
considère que vraiment c'est du gâchis
quoi d'une certaine et puis c'était pas
le moment on sort d'une pandémie il y a
le problème de l'inflation alors pour le
Président c'est peut-être le moment
parce que dans deux ans il aura moins
d'autorité pourraient pas le faire en
tous les cas ce type de réforme mais
c'était même plus acceptable s'il avait
fait dans 6 mois dans un an pour vous ça
serait mieux passé non je dis pas que ça
serait mieux passé c'est écrit il aura
moins de plus le temps va passer comme
il se peut pas se représenter plus il va
perdre de l'autorité ça c'est pas lui
c'est humain c'est d'une certaine
manière c'est la logique du système les
candidats de succession ont commencé à
s'exprimer etc donc lui si vous voulez
la faire c'est maintenant qu'il fallait
la faire certes mais il aurait ce qu'il
aurait dû faire selon moi c'est on a un
problème à terme de financement des
retraites donc on en discute mais c'est
vrai qu'il y a un problème sur l'âge
c'est pas un hasard si la France un des
pays où il y a le mieux possible plus
fort taux d'accidents du travail par
exemple il y a un problème non pas que
les gens veulent pas travailler c'est
pas ça mais un problème tout le monde le
reconnaît aujourd'hui de relations de
travail les gens ne se sentent mal dans
leur peau n'ont pas assez d'autonomie
etc on travaille d'abord là-dessus et
puis après on discute pour vous il faut
faire une réforme des retraites pas
celle-là on l'a compris il sait pas
celle que vous souhaitez mais est-ce
qu'il faut une réforme des retraites
bien sûr qu'il faut travailler sur les
questions d'air vous savez par exemple
que le taux de remplacement ce qu'on
appelle le taux de remplacement c'est le
niveau de la retraite par rapport au
dernier salaire d'activité il a baissé
depuis 20 ans et si on ne fait rien il
va continuer à baisser on doit être à
67% à peu près on va aller vers les 50%,
voilà c'est un autre élément donc il
faut retravailler le dossier mais il
faut le travailler en prenant le temps
et emmener en regardant tous les
éléments du tout il faudrait travailler
le dossier pour vous qu'est-ce qu'il
faut commencer par faire mais il faut
commencer par tout poser sur la table et
sans a priori des deux côtés regarde
tout on discute etc puis après on est
après la démocratie c'est quoi c'est
essayer de trouver le chemin qui donner
un compromis et quand on a compromis il
y a pas de problème ça se passe bien on
voit beaucoup vous avez été une figure
du syndicalisme et évidemment tous les
Français vous connaissent aujourd'hui on
entend beaucoup Laurent Berger on entend
beaucoup Philippe Martinez on entend
beaucoup moins Frédéric Souillot qui est
le nouveau patron de Force Ouvrière
est-ce que vous le regrettez ce que
Force ouvrière est en train de s'effacer
en pot non non je ne le crois pas moi se
porte bien même plutôt en interne etc
mais je le connais bien Frédéric
Souillot c'est un garçon brillant c'est
un vrai militant etc laissez-lui le
temps il a pas mal de boulot laisser lui
le temps ça viendra moi je suis pas
inquiet pour ça ça signifie pas pour
vous un effacement de force meilleur
face à la CGT dans la fonction publique
ils ont même progressé donc sur le
travail parlementaire puisque le texte
est actuellement à l'Assemblée il va
arriver au Sénat dans quelques jours
qu'est-ce que vous attendez du débat
parlementaire est-ce que quand on est
syndicalise comme vous ces grèves se
sont aussi un moyen de faire pression
sur les parlementaires ça veut dire que
vous on rencontre les parlementaires
quand c'est comme ça vous faire pression
c'est normal chacun a fait son boulot
quoi d'une certaine d'une manière
vous de rencontrer des parlementaires et
de leur dire voilà tel amendement ça
serait bien sûr je me souviens pendant
la loi travail avoir rencontré notamment
les frondeurs du Parti socialiste ce qui
avait mis en colère François Hollande
vous voyez donc ça existe d'une manière
d'une manière ou d'une autre dans chacun
fait son travail par contre je considère
que pratiquer de l'obstruction c'est pas
une bonne méthode il faut laisser le
débat se faire
je sais plus j'ai la France insoumise
avec 13000 abonnés sur le groupe pour
vous c'est pas la solution c'est pas la
solution parce que ça n'aurait on aborde
pas les questions il faut mieux
s'exprimer clairement y compris sur le
fameux article 7 qui concerne l'âge
chacun prend ses responsabilités mais
non non l'obstruction n'est pas une
solution
l'article 1 est-ce que vous dites à la
France insoumise retirez certains
amendements il faut absolument qu'il
faut qu'on arrive et que chacun
s'exprime après les gens verront qui a
voté quoi ça c'est c'est une autre paire
vous savez y compris des députés de la
majorité et quand il retourne concession
pendant les mois d'expression mais il se
fait engueuler ils savent bien que ça ne
passe pas alors ils peuvent pas le dire
publiquement mais ils savent bien que ça
se passe pas vous savez il y a un
problème de méthode je l'indiquais il y
a un problème de calendrier puis un
problème de contenu ça fait quand même
beaucoup il y a aussi l'épée du 49-3
puisque c'est budgétaire est-ce que du
coup ça peut démobiliser est-ce que les
syndicats au fond se disent ben de toute
façon il va finir par passer ce texte
non je pense pas qu'il soit dans ces
esprit là ils savent tout le monde sait
qu'il peut passer c'était une évidence
mais le film n'est pas fini et on
programme que le gouvernement peut
reculer alors on sait pas ce qui va se
passer dans les semaines à venir
regarder comment il gère grande
manifestations demain il y a d'autres
dates d'annoncées le 7 le 16 le 7 le 8
il y aura des choses aussi donc il
s'inscrivent dans un mouvement en tous
les cas après on va pas programmer ce
qui va se passer à la fin du mois de
mars voilà chaque chose en son temps
merci beaucoup Jean-Pierre merci d'avoir
été avec nous au centre secrétaire
général de Force Ouvrière merci de nous
avoir livré votre regard sur cette
réforme